the David Pakman show is launching
YouTube sponsorships this is a beta
feature that u2 has launched it's not
yet open to all channels and the david
pakman show has been specially invited
to participate here this is a direct way
for our more than 430 thousand YouTube
subscribers to support our program for
$4.99 per month there are all sorts of
great sponsorship benefits including
that you will get a sponsors only badge
or icon next to your name in live chat
during our live streams there will be
sponsors only posts on the community tab
there will be sponsors only thank-you
videos you will get early access to
long-form deep dive videos on YouTube
and we will even have sponsors only
polls to choose upcoming long-form deep
dive videos so a lot of really really
cool stuff and it's really important to
understand that this is if you haven't
heard of this before this is a beta and
that's why we have a feature that you
want might not be seeing on every other
channel that you follow additionally if
there are problems with it bear in mind
that it is a beta program and YouTube is
still working on the full rollout of it
currently you can't sign up on iOS
that's functionality that's still being
added in the meantime you can sign up on
desktop at youtube.com slash the david
pakman show or on the android youtube
app at the david pakman show YouTube
channel and then you'll be able to get
all the benefits on iOS when it launches
including the sponsors only posts on the
community tab this is so exciting I feel
like we should launch something called
the 1% project because basically if we
can get just 1% of our four hundred and
thirty plus thousand YouTube subscribers
to become sponsors at $4.99 a month just
1% we will solve all financial funding
issues for the David Pakman show
. so check it out become a
sponsor of the David Pakman show YouTube
channel new feature that we've been
invited into and I hope you'll join me
take part this is one time we're being
part of the 1% is a really great and
moral thing because you're you're going
to be supporting independent media in a
way that number one a lot of YouTube
channels don't even have as a feature
available yet and number two you will be
part of this elite but it doesn't
require fancy lawyers and accountants in
order to join isn't that great